what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation gonna do a first time
watching today for a movie that I I know
literally nothing about nothing at all
called Coraline and I am joined today by
returning co-host Michael from Omni
media Michael how's it going Mikey I'm
running on coffee Greg running on coffee
with Michael
um and doing great band a bad man I'm
running on no capping
we're gonna watch this dark movie all
I've heard is that it's an animated
movie that's a little bit darker than
people thought let's see whatever the
heck that means ladies and gentlemen if
you can leave a like we would love that
very much also um you can subscribe to
our Channel but also subscribe to
omnimedia he does plenty of reactions
all the time dude never sleeps he's a
living vampire it's great he's our own
our own morbius in our lives also full
length to action watch as long as you
sync up with your own copy for Coraline
available for super sexy rejects that's
how we met Michael if you want to collab
with us all you got to do is roll the
dice there and see if I hit you up one
day I think we're good to go let's uh
let's get this going are you excited
let's do it let's do it what we're
getting into Coraline Coraline let's go
[Music]
Dakota Fanning
Terry Hatcher
I don't know who that is uh yeah you
lost me already
weird
I do find dolls fairly unsettling
intro man oh my God this is disturbing
well in the beginning of the movie
ah
what is wrong with this cat
it's barely alive
[Music]
I really like the animation though I
know it's beautiful and this music man
this is the kind of movie I normally
zone out to on my couch
this is like I would say like if you put
just put this on while right now
while you're like trying to unwind like
the music would just like put you out
man
wow
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
he dumb pissed off that cat I'm just
looking for an old well
know it
magic dowser show me
well
[Music]
whoa what in those what is happening
foreign
erds or their cats he's not really my
cat of course I do feed him every night
and sometimes they'll come in my window
that cat is sick man yeah
where's the secret well you stop too
hard and you'll fall in it
the mushrooms were a clue my grandma she
owns the Pink Palace you won't rented
people with kids what do you mean
oh I'm not supposed to talk about it I'm
YB why below that YB short for why born
not my idea of course that's mean
Coraline Jones hmm it's not real
scientific but I heard an ordinary name
like Caroline can lead people to have
ordinary expectations about a person
sure
definitely hurt someone
why were you born oh that's mean it's
been a little unnecessarily mean here
why because that dowsing Rod of yours
it's poison oak
oh no that's awful
you can't just wipe that off nope
too late who knows maybe she's lucky and
she doesn't have get a reaction from it
yeah
well today Mom I would have died
that's nice
[Laughter]
I think it's perfect weather for
gardening no Coraline rain makes mud mud
makes a mess I can't believe it
you and Dad get paid to write about
plants and you hate dirt Coraline
some kid left this on the front porch
huh wow well that's really eerie that's
oh like that
look at that man's neck
[Music]
why does this guy look like this
specific
character design look familiar to me
what'd the boss say
[Music]
[Laughter]
this house is 150 years old so so
explore it go out and count all the
doors and windows and write that down on
list everything that's blue just let me
work
oh
she's neglected
[Music]
oh life
[Laughter]
great thing about this animation is it
really captures movement really well
yeah
in the world end up with your bare hands
[Music]
I know this pain
I know her this is too relatable man I'm
Coraline
[Music]
no no no no no no no
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
such a wonderful ethereal mood to all
this
what in the world
[Music]
yeah I don't know about that
huh there's some neat shots
yeah oh
secret tunnel I'm really
[Music]
yeah with wallpaper
my heart molts
[Music]
so many keys
with a button shaped
pommel on it
damn you nailed down that one key
it they must have closed this off when
they divided up the house you're kidding
and
they're so small we made a deal
you didn't lock it
[Laughter]
it's more like slime to me well it's
slime or bedtime fuss pot now What's it
gonna be I think they're trying to
poison me
like that
a quaint little room with that little
window outcrop it's nice yeah that's not
for being a grateful Coraline
[Music]
oh my God yeah nah nah I'm good
go through a Coraline
[Music]
yes
oh my gosh she's some alternate reality
mom
yikes
no geez
my mother doesn't have buttons
do you like them I'm your other mother
silly now go tell your other father that
supper's ready
the mitt has a button on it
[Music]
huh
hello
hello
Coraline yep nope my father
no need to
what this piano plays me
foreign
they're like human puppets wait can they
actually see though with the button nice
ah yes he assumes
it's the gravy train I could have sworn
for a second that was Tom was the Tank
Engine just because the coloration
mango milkshake
what is this world a trauma responds to
or neglect
uh I could see that she's getting
everything she wants and the attention
and everything as soon as you're through
eating I thought we'd play a game
in the rain
ah
I better get home to my other mother but
I'm your other mother
I think I should get to bed of course
sweetheart it's all made up it's all
made up
now there's a mystery
what's shaking baby
interesting
dream so wouldn't there be an another
Coraline
they've got the bug in the eyes and all
that so I'm wondering if somehow the
doll is the other Coraline but ended up
here and when the doll ends up and hit
this world they end up as a doll
because I have a
tater's rash on my um
dude that dad looks like he's decaying
viserys Targaryen over here
somebody else lived there the whole time
I think our mail got mixed up
should I leave it outside or
just go in just like Toby McGuire just
go in
Alan Tudyk
what in the world new cheese samples
yeah
very clever using this mix up to sneak
my home and peek at mush what is this
Anatomy I don't know
what
this guy's really disturbing have beat
make you strong
that's vadanya got a lie
that dude's like a fat praying mantis
jumping mice mice they are seeing do not
go through little door
it's all bricked up sometimes the mice
are a little mixed up
[Music]
like he looks like a strung out Dr
Robotnik
all right
oh here we go are those dogs real
ah sweet departed Angels couldn't bear
the part with them so we had them
stuffed oh you should have buried them
oh your tea leaves dear they'll tell me
your future
drink up then go on her voice sounds
really familiar
you are intense table Danger
oh what you're holding it wrong
see danger what
see you very peculiar hand I see a
giraffe
never wear green in your dressing room
acquire a very tall step ladder and be
very very careful
one in the world
these are really off-putting Neighbors
it's YB
this juice played way too much siphon
filter
damn
it's really cool animation though man
yeah that doll did you make it look like
me oh no
I found it that way
old is his house probably come on blue
hair my Swampers and raincoat dang check
out slugzilla oh gross my parents they
don't listen to me either you mind
no oh okay
what you are a creepy ass kid I've never
been inside the Pink Palace you're
kidding
Grandma kill me I think it's dangerous
or something
dangerous that's a common word today
when they were kids Grandma's sister
there's a real mystery of foot here
yeah
I know people were like this movie so
dark doesn't seem that dark
I bet he's hungry as a pumpkin by now
you mean
you're better father
yes it's like manifestation thing
it feels like it
because it seems so far it only happens
when she goes to bed too
you know the sound design there
gorgeous yeah I know it's very
Illuminating
what in the world
[Music]
is that a praying mantis yeah with
wheels it's very expressive this movie
do we have like others of the whole
neighborhood
[Music]
yeah
hello why were you born
hello oh my God he doesn't talk I
thought you'd like him more if he spoke
a little
so I fixed him
what'd you do I like it what no you're
right along YouTube why can't he talk
why be so silent
[Laughter]
oh
oh this is welcoming
[Music]
oh my goodness they spelled her name
right
you adjusted things really fast Coraline
yeah
yeah concerned at all that he was like
physically altered for your pleasure
line
oh
what do the butter knives mean it's like
a world that she can control
I don't know puppets
dolls that she can control she's playing
pretend I saw a real Mouse circus not
pretend like the crazy man's in our
house maybe they'll love the new catalog
at least they'll love my chapters wow
rude you guys are super neglectful
she really just you know you might have
just nailed it on the head at the very
beginning of the movie Michael
is this just sad man yeah put them back
my other mother would get them oh maybe
she should buy all your clothes maybe
she should and then other mother will
kill you
and become the real mother
the only mother
what in the hell is this you can't take
care of the fridge had to go food
shopping anyway
you want to come along you can pick out
something you like oh like the gloves
if things go well today I promise I'll
make it up
always say I'll make it up
I'll [ __ ] you I mean it's got to be
hard but at the same time they're not
going
a great job keeping a
inner headspace Michael with you and I
not being parents I think we have every
right to say what kind of parents they
should be you are correct
trash parents man abusive as hell
quit all of your jobs and just focus on
your daughter
[Music]
I don't know there's something that
reads Sinister about this other side it
might be the button eyes
and the uh extraction of vocal
that's not quite it
that cat's honestly there's some
witchcraft Happening Here think and Miss
forcible have invited you downstairs
after lunch I hope you oh I wonder what
they're
probably they're like skinny Jazz
versions of themselves
you must be the other cat
whoa the other anything I'm me there's
Keith yeah she hates cat
It's gotta keep me up but she can of
course hmm you probably think this world
is a dream come true
you're wrong the other YB told me so
what
[Music]
day oh the eyes and the people on the
back are moving
oh wow
[Laughter]
oh goodness I could go for Darkness I
did not expect something that's
revealing
oh no
she's a reverse mermaid now
that did not seem like the ideal world
oh whoa what the hell
they are their skinny selves in there
[Music]
and now you're stuck this is such a
strange film
I'm mystified by it though
hmm
are you you're creepy I don't know about
you Mom I don't know about my real mom
either
one time little thing we need to do
what's that murder modernize
butter nice
black is traditional
stay here so sharp you won't feel it how
far is this movie gonna go I don't know
man
oh I just need to sleep on things
we aren't worried at all darling
soon you'll see things
our way
they're a skewed vision of buttons
[Music]
fell out of their Coraline
[Music]
and I won't be back
[Music]
what's so bad about getting some buttons
for us no no they seem to be fine
foreign
[Music]
what's happening
if you won't even talk to me I'm gonna
find the other Whitey he'll help me no
point he pulled a long face
[Music]
oh my god mother controls all just like
on the other side this is like
everything everywhere all at once but
nothing you didn't like everything
everywhere
I mean on the other side her real father
was all like you know it's it's she's
the boss huh
how can you walk away from something and
still come back to it because that's
life
[Music]
oh my God
what is happening here I don't like rats
at the
facade
of course chocolate never hurts like one
no I'm okay
oh my God
yeah that was not Coco you aren't my
mother apologize
at once
Coraline
no
I'll give you
to the count of three
no one
two
uh
what are you doing oh no
[Music]
it's like Cruella Deville what is she
this is like a real case of the grass is
greener on the other side then you're
there and it's all the same if not worse
don't remember our names
but I remember my true Mommy
this is like the black phone
yeah
through the little doll's eyes
and saw that we weren't happy oh my God
you could find out
has she taken those two yes Miss and
hidden them find our eyes mistress and
our souls will be free
or dead kids
fly me yeah
no
hey what's up with his mouth oh wow did
he slice it open did she do this to you
oh no
she's making him smile
[Music]
oh
oh it is a disgusting hole
[Music]
thank you YB
what if she's been gone for like 20
years
oh my Lord
that would be terrible
your parents are dead
[Music]
no dollar I gave you
um my grandma's real mad says it was her
sisters Grandma's missing sister
I think I just met her come on
where are her parents yeah are there a
bunch of other questions
you're crazy
[Music]
wow
were they abducted or something I mean
that's what I'm thinking
what's it for well it might help they're
good for bad things those things April
bad loss bad lost bad lust I like to
think every one of these choices have a
meaning but some of it I think is just
really random
this is one of those uh
movies like you gotta you probably have
to watch a couple times
let's watch it again right after yes
we don't need to sleep
[Music]
oh you gave her the neck brace now you
appreciate them huh
to be fair she's just wanted their
attention this entire time anyway
hello how did you get in
do you know where Mom and Dad are
oh you can't now he went from
disgustingly cute
oh my God they're hanging in the living
room
what the heck
oh I would not put that cat on the glass
oh my God
oh my God
does that have consequences
they were cold because they were under
the bed now they're on fire
you know you're walking right into a
trap she may not play fair but she won't
refuse she's got a thing for games it's
sort of a bit crazy to see in the
theaters
yeah
where are my parents gosh I have no idea
where your old parents are
perhaps they've grown bored of you and
run away to France they weren't bored of
me you stole them oh wow yikes
yikes
what has become of him
why don't you have your own key
[Music]
oh God
why don't we play a game
I know you like them you want to play a
game called remove the buttons from your
eyes
my real parents and the eyes of the
ghost children what if you don't find
them
if I lose I'll let you sew buttons into
my eyes oh God
in each of three wonders I've made just
for you a ghost's eye is Lost In Plain
Sight
and for my parents
hmm
I don't get it hmm
oh yikes
[Music]
must be it
oh geez this poor man
[Music]
oh
tomorrow Papa he was so nice I like how
the mom in both worlds is portrayed as
just awful yeah someone's working
through some stuff
[Music]
are you
foreign
yeah they're like I actually wrapped up
one of those taffies or whatever
um
what is happening
oh my God they're wrapped up
oh my God
no they get stuck they're gonna get
stuck
oh maybe
oh I know she only cares about this YB
I know
is this what you're looking for
uh-huh
you think winning game is good team
I'm gonna have great dreams tonight I
can feel it
so easy is he right now
I don't know a rat or a series of rats
oh
oh my God Michael you're right
[Music]
oh these goddammers these tricky little
bastards this movie's wild man
foreign
what does the button symbolize oh God
lost the game
there's still time Coraline
[Music]
it looked like you
like you cool cat I
there is so much asked of this Coraline
what the with the realities distorting
and breaking apart we're in The Matrix
[Applause]
only the house is safe
that's
that's
hmm
unless this is just like it's true for
all really did itself going to the
foundation you still need to find your
old parents too bad you won't have
this
you cruel-hearted lady
[Music]
I already know where you've hidden them
they're behind that door
ah Detroit Zoo
you're wrong Coraline she's so creepy
yeah now
no
no
no
I'm
[Music]
why would you throw the cat
she's got needle hands the cat's been so
helpful
[Music]
foreign
wow holy crap man
where are you
selfish brat
yikes this is okay it's pretty darn
sweet
Ah that's so creepy
yes dead kids
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh wow
that was scary
are they Carline thank God we got a lot
to celebrate you're talking about your
Garden catalog what else
[Music]
what's wrong with you idiots
bunch of dumbass parents you should have
gotten butter on her eyes
stay here stay there crazy lady
it wasn't a present or a mousetrap I
couldn't tell
gloves
the 25 gloves this whole thing was a
black mold hallucination
that's hilarious
it was all I could think of
no
what a forgiving cat but we still don't
like YB yeah
whoa
what in The Starry Night your entire
girl what
we were done the key Miss there's only
one and the Belden will find it
I gotta hide this somewhere somewhere
she can never
just leave it in the keyhole she would
never say well
oh the spot the the part where YB was
showing her earlier in the movie
with the well oh yeah the well the thing
you pointed out
oh my God
it's like [ __ ] Freddy man
it's gonna turn into a new nightmare
here soon
ah
this is so wild man
[Music]
our favorite stalker
[Music]
oh my God
that would have been so funny if they
just killed off why
nice crazy
that's why we have any idea of what's
going on
I don't know man
he was all like skeptical earlier and
now he was like let's murder this
sentient hand
Grandma showed me this picture
after I called you crazy
the sweet ghost girl
the sweet goks girl
we can tell her again
we can you know
I'm glad you decided to stalk me
no woman has ever told me that
I I don't quite get to what's
a weird ending hello
Mr was murdered in this house
very specifically to tell you
foreign
wow wow what if
I went on a journey there I was just I
was just like zoned out on that film the
whole time
that's so good though so creepy
oh wow dude that was a that was a Trippy
ass film
what we got
[Music]
stop motion rig
ah
that's neat
I I like that
laughs
something deeper there going back I'm
sure jerk one all right well
that was a
a really vivid imagination down the
subconscious corridors of abuse
and neglect and neglect that I did not
think I'd be walking into today before
we filmed we were trying to watch
another movie we couldn't get it to load
and then we're like well I got Coraline
on the list and I was like I don't know
anything about Coraline and from what
I've heard about it it sounds like I
really gotta pay attention and I don't
know if my brain could absorb it and I
really enjoyed it uh it was really
haunting and very expressive uh but yeah
there's it's like wow what a
what a very thought-provoking movie that
I was I was like warped into and
I I felt like I was just I think it's
like ethereal hypnotic abilities we're
sort of working on me throughout I was
like okay yeah whoa I just I'm kind of
like
ready to it was one of those things like
I'm ready to close my eyes and just let
my mind just see the imagery in there I
was getting sucked into this other world
but what do you think Michael did you
like it I really did enjoy it man and
like you said like the I think
that kind of surreal
otherworldly like
state it kind of puts you in with
everything going on with the visual
effects like just the art Direction the
design and all that it's just and then
that that score and it just like it
creates this
this mood this vibe that just kind of
like lulls you into this
like I almost want to say false sense of
security oh exactly exactly yeah
definitely and oh my Lord man which is
uh which works on the
on the themes of domestic violence you
know got to be a little bit careful with
our words but she's like
it it is I keep trying to nail down what
the hell the buttons represent I can't
or like I don't even have a real
interpretation
for it
um I mean I think it could be just you
know because it's not sewing your eyes
shut like you can still see
uh so that's why I'm like I don't know
what it means I've been trying to figure
that out do you have an interpretation
yeah I mean the only thing like even
remotely close but it still doesn't
necessarily explain the buttons itself
is like there's this kind of theme of
like
because of the neglect that's going on
in the home for her with her parents
having their priorities on everything
other than her yeah at that point like
forces her to kind of like
she they just moved this places to her
run down isolated there's a bunch of
weirdos everywhere there's this stalker
kid running around this cat with mange
so like there's this perception of like
you know
it's this is we're take at first glance
we're taking everything in as this
negative
like surroundings so like and then she
gets this idea she goes to sleep and she
thinks of all the things that she would
want to see and want to have and the
house is brighter the garden's full and
Lively and her neighbors aren't as we
they're still weird but they're like not
as off-putting they're more welcoming so
it's like everything is kind of like
this
weird warped
like perfect version at first of what
she's hoping this place would be with
her family
and then
so I don't even know what I'm trying to
say at this point yeah I asked her so
there's like this I know but I'm just
like it I mean if I kind of wonder if
the buttons mean something's as basic
as you know because like they talk about
the mother
the the other mother uh wanting you know
someone to
to love you know if there's something
that as a subject in my life of domestic
violence is is a subject I'm
you know know about for sure you know
without going into too many personal
details uh it's it's a subject I'm very
much familiar with and and something I
hold near and dear to my like you know I
look into Charities and [ __ ] and it's
often something with that so
um
yeah and and
you know like there are those kind of
parents where
a lot of the times with like a
domestically violent parent with this
type of like gaslighting and narcissism
and self-serving where it's like this
false sense of Allure with with love but
then underneath that is it's it's all a
big manipulation tactic of possession
and if we're looking at the buttons as a
symbolic reasoning for the dolls it's
like keeping the
whoever like by her having them putting
them with the button eyes that keeps
them as their their dolls a thing to
control like anything to control so it's
like the most basic thing because I'm
like that's what the movie feels like
it's telling me yeah but I keep writing
going like zero like something deeper
about the buttons themselves that I'm
not showing your eyes shut yeah I don't
I don't quite know
um but I imagine like I feel like the
former is a part of it but that's one of
the cool things about this film is like
you said it while we were watching it
there's many ways of
like revisiting this would allow one to
get to know where it's going would it'll
make it easier to kind of interpret
certain choices or interpret certain
meanings and perhaps pick up other Clues
and whatnot because it doesn't really
take the full
like horror direction or or the the true
unveiling of what's going on in the
other world until like close to an hour
into the movie it takes a while before
we before we actually find out for that
it's just sort of this Insidious build
to like I knew something messed up is
going on but I don't quite know what's
messed up that's going on so it really
puts you in like Coraline shoes of yeah
why would a nice day here look at this
this is amazing um but then
it's not and it's also like you know a
lot of praise and a lot of feelings of
loneliness and wanting to belong
um and in some ways generational trauma
of like that's what the other mom wants
and
Coraline is also very lonely and wants
uh
wants someone to connect to because like
you said neglect so yeah there's some
there's some deeper
there's some deep [ __ ] happening here is
what I'm trying to say yeah I like to go
and put your go on to what you were
saying like that build up like when
she's going into that other world
there's this idea of uh
like looks can be deceiving you know
everything looked great but like even
for like from the other side you know
sometimes you might look at that other
family or look at that you know other
person in your life whether it be a
friend family member whoever maybe it's
like oh man if only my life was like
theirs or whatever but you have like no
idea what's going on on the back side of
that exactly so it's like what happened
there where she's like oh this is great
look my dad's awesome here my mom's
awesome here and then when she goes back
the dad is like literally a meat puppet
yeah
at the wheel of this other mom and all
that it's like the things start to kind
of show themselves the cracks start to
form the more she's around it and it's
also like she's a life or sucker and uh
yeah like this smothering energy that
will just drain you
the eyes are the windows to the soul
that she's clogging that up or taking
that yeah trapping them but that's
another way to doubt it look at it yeah
oh my God I couldn't work my brain I
could make [ __ ] up
foreign
and it also taught us a valuable lesson
kids it is okay to be a stalker it's
okay to be a stalker if it leads to you
being a hero in the end every young
man's dream
is to stuck and then be rewarded
uh that's what I would want the black
cat was cool I mean everything on like
it's easy to look at this film and want
to like kind of deconstruct all its
deeper meanings but I think on like a
technical level it's just it's as
outstanding animation like this is 2009
and it's still so
so striking
um like I love the movement because it's
a stop-motion and one of my favorite
Parts about stop motion is is capturing
the movement and the movement is so it
that's one of the biggest alluring parts
and I do like that it leans into this
Whimsy eccentricity about it it's it's a
strange film and every regard and like
there's a lot of things I'm just like I
don't I don't even care to try to figure
out what it represents I just think it's
weird uh like the like the tubes
imagination yeah the imagination of it
all just kind of creeps in and the way
that it just kind of uh
both within the story and just within
the art Direction as a whole creates
this like dreamlike quality of the whole
thing right they're not really
you know Bound by being
hyper realistic or anything like that it
allows them to really kind of free flow
and do some really interesting stuff
with the shots the Angles and the
expressions and
all kinds of really fun stuff and plus
it's just a fantastic
Art House man
so like they knocked out of the park
with this one this I mean it's like some
of it I didn't like like I feel like the
the main themes of what is they're going
for I'm picking up on but there's other
things that I'm like look I don't I
don't know what the mice mean I don't
know what the two like creepy theater
ladies have dog audience really means
I'm just like watching it going that's
just strange like that's all I got for
you it's it's strange or I don't know
what it means it's just freaking weird
it's all like there's someone much
smarter than myself out there who has
decided to do a whole bunch of research
and read the book to compare to the
movies and then go and this is what it
means and I watch it on my first go
around and I'm like I don't know which
is [ __ ] bizarre like that's [ __ ]
Dogwood dog wings and Taffy like I don't
I don't care what it means being stuck
in this world or something like I I
don't know why dogs specifically or bat
dogs like it's a really strange thing
snowing gaming like everything probably
has like a very specific
purpose yeah well that's like an Alice
in Wonderland Vibe too yeah always yeah
for sure
but yeah it was gorgeous it was gorgeous
and scary too it's like pretty scary at
times
dude if I if I saw this like
when I was a kid that'd probably be
pretty freaked out I mean there were
some freaking alive man there were Parts
in the I was imagining like what if I
was as an adult watching this in the
theaters I'd be like this is pretty
freaking horrifying you know like it
escalates into something that that gets
progressively scarier you know and uh I
can't imagine being a kid watching this
like when it's rated PG and I just I
don't know I don't see it I don't see it
man I feel like it'd be about 13. ah
well
man it's also very important it's very
unpredictable too and um
and and uh yeah so I'm wanting that
sense of belonging yeah I I thought it
was actually kind of beautiful and
creepy you know it was like right
wonderful color palette throughout uh it
was awesome it was so vivid like the
entire way through
um and Terry Hatcher was the mom
yeah she did a great job on that
um
and great Dakota was Coraline I'm
assuming yeah and uh I think I think Ian
McShane was uh the babinsky yeah yeah
yeah yeah I I Heard it Through the
voices yeah
um
another thing I think like she was
turning we saw like him riding the
mechanical mantis or whatever and then
she was kind of turning very mantoid at
the end and the man and mantises the
females eat the males okay
I'm just like still like making a [ __ ]
dude
I mean hey if you're probably right man
like I don't know
I don't I'm like I don't know about
these animals to know what the hell they
representing at the end of the day man
bare minimum bare Bode straight forward
it's a great story
it's a great story with the the whole
like to me I mean the most obvious
correlation is it is a correlation of
like a of a like neglect is a form of
abuse and it is and it is like a of a
big correlation of an abusive household
and whether or not it's uh I mean to me
the movie takes a
takes a
a choice to be literal you know instead
of taking the choice of
is this in her head is it not in her
head to me it took the choice that no
this is not in her head especially when
you got like I don't know how the book
uh plays out obviously but with uh with
YB you know
um fighting the hand at the very end
right I want to introduce grandma and
stuff like to me I'm like okay this is
definitely because I was still like
questionable about it uh you know when
the when the parents come out through
the broken snow globe and they're like
honey we're home and they're and they're
just disregarding yeah I'm like okay
maybe it's still in court that could be
a coincidence yeah yeah no but like
their food was like all rotted and [ __ ]
uh so I don't know um what but was it uh
because our keys were also still in the
car and the car was still at the house
that when that happened so it's like it
played that line
while that's happening in the middle I
think it's fair to say that who knows
what's going on but like by the end of
it I agree with you I think they really
kind of like cemented that yeah all this
stuff definitely happened at the end
yeah and I like I I respect rather
taking a choice
um in in that regard like I just like
just make a choice and I like that they
made a choice to like I'm gonna stick
with this is this is this really did
happen so especially with her why be
happening and you know a lot of times
like kids can be more open to things
that are greater than you know life like
don't be like Thinking Beyond The
Realistic quote unquote right delving
into the imagination and how that
imagination can be more real and
attainable for through the youth eyes I
think is a great call and also just had
a great sense of atmosphere too I gotta
point that out it was a one yeah it was
a really this is a hard film to make
like thinking about stop-motion like
that this film must have been a [ __ ] to
put together because yeah this amount of
crew that it had to assemble this and
then adapting Neil gaiman's work I can't
imagine is the easiest thing in the
world you know to make something that's
really cohesive
unless you got Neil Gaiman on staff like
Sandman was he uh was he part of this uh
because he didn't say that he wrote it
um
um book obviously but right I'm not sure
like if he actually had like a
producer's credit or anything of the
sort
uh I don't know
I don't remember I just saw that it was
based on his book
yeah
um
well yeah I don't know
it's a good question
I don't know I don't know but I like how
the parents didn't learn anything in the
end though yeah I know but she learned
to appreciate them and go it's okay that
they kind of ignore me
neglect is okay it's okay because I went
through there's a much there's something
much worse out there
um but you know it's I I I got the
impression rather than telling
I got the impression that it was an
adult working through childhood trauma
versus an adult telling kids how to
react to their parents right because you
know like that's often what happens is
you know you might go through some
some things that were traumatic and then
when you get older you start to kind of
be pissed off at your parents for what
happened to you and then you get a
little bit older and you're like well
they didn't really realize what they
were doing and they were doing their
best at the end of the day to take care
of me and they still loved me you know
and then there's a lot of things that
you learn as an adult that you're like
oh okay I see what all they were also
dealing with while also trying to deal
with me so there's like a level of
understanding that you develop too as
you get older exactly that too exactly
which are like which is kind of what I
said earlier in the movie when I was
definitely giving the parents the
benefit of the doubt yeah yeah if they
don't do what they're here to do like
there won't be food on the table so like
we used to catch 22 situations so like I
get it it's just like from the point of
view of the kid like that's kind of
where you're they're putting your head
space in with the film at first yeah
because even the way she sometimes is
with like other people and stuff like
Coraline you could see sort of morphing
into her mom in some ways yes and and uh
the way she's with especially with YB
it's like I like the one who doesn't
talk you know uh she is she learns to
sort of perhaps because the thing with
generational trauma too is you have to
kind of learn to break that cycle so I
could see a version of this where it is
her breaking the cycle
while being a film about wonder and
Whimsy and being what weird you know
it says it's it's inventive man it's
creative as [ __ ] it's really it's really
it's really awesome stuff
um I wonder if it was made for 3D
because there were parts of it that felt
like it should have been 3D
it's a little bit around that point
where 3D was popping yeah
yeah
well
we did it man
we tried sounding smart
[Laughter]
the best we could do is try is try to
pull some [ __ ] out of your ass and
connect it but yeah it was released in
3D it was okay there were shots that
looked like it was there were shots that
looked like it was in 3D
um that I was like I wonder uh so yeah
that makes sense
fascinating man
just reading some fun IMDb facts here
alrighty well there we go everything on
a technical standpoint from
music the sound design to obviously
animation was great some wonderful voice
performances brought to life felt like
they're real performers
and
um
you know I did a lot like I only really
enjoyed two characters which were the
most since Coraline like that yeah if
there's one thing that was kind of
missing for me was there's there's other
characters you're coming around too and
I didn't really care about any of them
other than Coraline and the mom the
other mom like there were the two and
the cat I like the cat too uh like they
were the ones I was most I I really
enjoyed being around but the other ones
that well there's always like this sort
of distance with me right you're just
like bizarre I don't really I like I
like quiet I mean I'm kind of a Coraline
I like quiet YB I don't really care for
talking and wiping why being like quiet
you know mouth Zone
he's mildly endeared to the father but
I'm right there with you on everything
else all the tertiary characters were
just kind of like oh that was they're
weird
they were fun to visit for a little bit
they're eccentric but you know I don't
really care about them like they're
cutting down all them at the end like I
don't really I don't it's not really
doing anything for me when they're
showing all of them at the end but hey
I'm just happy Coraline's happy you know
all right guys well that's it
um what do you guys think about Coraline
do you like it leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe and leave a
like follow Michael
buy omnimedia over on his YouTube
channel where he's doing reactions at
the time of filming this what is the
latest things you've reacted to
let me see this let me see this I'm
currently going through Umbrella Academy
For the First Time congratulations
uh if you want more Neil Gaiman I did
the Sandman nice you're doing season two
of that coming on yes we are both doing
Chucky
Titans
Titans is doing literally you you asked
me and like my brain went blank I was
like what am I
the Midnight Club oh is the Midnight
Club good I haven't seen anything for it
I really yeah the marketing was terrible
for this thing man every time I saw the
marketing for it it was just images of
other Mike Flanagan stuff and I didn't
understand I was like is this just like
a recap of his work I don't know what
this is
um think of it like it it's a
I don't even know how to describe it
it's
anyway it's it's good it was a lot of
fun it's a little more younger skewed
um compared to some of his other
previous series at least but I think it
like as far as like the subject material
and all that I think it was pretty
pretty solid but
it yeah it's uh I think it was hoping
for a season two but I don't know if
it's gonna get one
your Doctor Who reactions popping
there's the
yeah what else do you got here
how was the last season of The Walking
Dead now I'm just talking to Michael
it is okay oh
they they they're playing with the hole
they dug themselves in two three seasons
ago so
bad it's so fun but like there's a lot
of it that just feels missing
with everything that it kind of was
outside of their control at least and
it's the last season what are you gonna
do
yeah but there's like 18 spin-offs
coming so it's not really done
those are still going
uh
uh two are still green lit and then a
mini series with Rick the movies that
were planned with Rick are now a limited
series that's stupid instead I feel bad
for him I'm sure he was excited to have
a movie
it was supposed to be a Trilogy I think
from what I remember yeah what are you
gonna do
um all righty well buddy I will talk
with you soon
see a reject Nation bye
[Music]